[Music]
in funny types news submitted by yonas
froyo Tesfaye
is that pig latin sounds like you're not
fond at us today I have no idea sounds
like royalty it's not like it made me
say something offensive in another
language and I don't know yeah it's in
Finnish don't say it don't say it means
your mother is a is a is a is a rotten
salmon
oh that's [ __ ] up
how dare you here are nine different
types of humor which one are you
Oh Hugh Murr sarcastic dry dark like all
types of humor I did you sample a little
bit of every absurdist yeah oh I like
that it's a data scientists at eat
harmony that already sounds funny they
conducted research so they can use these
results to better match people s key so
they found that there are nine different
types of humor so the first one is
physical
so like slapstick I love that whenever
people get hurt
like pretty much everything on Funniest
Home Videos not all your be nude the
best [ __ ]
I like watching fail videos especially
girls compilation nut shot videos are
great oh nice shot videos yeah yeah has
in fall involves physicality number two
self-deprecating
type of humor hmm it's like fan of
comedian kind of humor where they make
themselves the butt of the joke like
your first five minutes where you just
like destroy yourself so that everyone
likes you it's like everything that it's
a clever about I like it when it's
cringy I don't like it oh yeah I'm gonna
stop Rodney Dangerfield like was to me
the best of that enough to understand
his jokes there was a this time at a
comedy club like I would I just said it
was at the ice house and every single
community like a bit about themselves in
the beginning and I just like oh god I
can't stand this [ __ ] because it's so
cringy you mean open yours I don't
remember I think I you start talking
yeah you know I mean they fill out the
crowd and whatever then you start going
into a joke but it
literally it would be like look at my
nose isn't it weird and then the next
person would be like of a fat guy and
then the next one would be like yeah I'm
not a really hot girl and it's like oh
god dude and after a while the college
is like it's all the same same probably
went to a night where they all took the
same class and they're the same format
it's like you know at that I was like
what in the [ __ ] is going on man
yeah I hate it when I see that guy Asian
comedian come on and the first thing he
says it's like guess how many cars are
crashed into driving over here oh I like
all my car dude they just need to evolve
the joke I [ __ ] hate that whole on
take it real quick don't see yeah I love
the whole like like I'm a guy seen up
and I'm like huh so I jerk off a lot
it's like oh look that's the chick lick
my vagina it's like that that stereotype
it's the same [ __ ] oh boy how would you
tired because when I open it I don't
know it depends on well you like you
want crowd to look at the crowd you feel
it out but you but you definitely I mean
if you're Conan cold I think the great
thing to do is the self-deprecating like
to make people like you especially if
you if you come across like Nikki right
like when people see Mickey and she's
doing stand-up they're like oh great
some attractive girl who think she's
funny right like that's what that's what
you're gonna immediately think when you
see her and so she has to take that away
from you because that's how you're
typecasting her
and so the her job is to deconstruct
herself to do that right so it just
depends on who you are gonna can have
what you look like and what how people
perceive you
there's some great [ __ ] out there like
oh this is out there where you can you
take the class and throughout the class
you discover like how people perceive
you cuz it's way different than even
what you think like people fill out a
thing like they look at you and they go
like well he probably thinks he's the
[ __ ] or he probably he talks like this
so he probably thinks he's like awesome
and [ __ ] so you don't even know about
yourself I want to take that because I'm
so sure I'm gonna walk up on stage to
play my gonna [ __ ] die he thinks he's
so cool yes he's so smart he's popular
oh yeah [ __ ] let me show you you
already won you already won the
perceptions of yourself is clucking
amazing I love it
you think he's cool look at the guy's
[ __ ] shoes dangling [ __ ] just want you
swaying in front of me like a pendulum
and [ __ ] god that's why you got to tell
them the opposite alright next one is
surreal humor I love that [ __ ] what is
that [ __ ] I like to burn [ __ ] wait what
do you love then I love that way to sit
cuz I guessed it don't understand it's
like it's like well it's like Wayans
brothers kinda like with like over the
top well this is what they wrote the
style humor can be pretty weird
featuring illogical events absurd
situations and nonsensical theme yeah
that is way to the fireman thing that
Jim Carrey din like it's like fire
marshal bill yeah fire marshal pole like
that's like surreal and absurd like
Shaolin Soccer
yeah sure exactly like that kung fu team
becomes yeah yeah I like that so so Tim
burn doesn't fall into that category
I think he kind of does timber does he
do it's a wide swath no but the comedy
that exists in the Tim Burton world oh I
love just straddling to burden to work I
love his work don't like Tim Burton I
thought you would like it because you
like that [ __ ] unfortunate events
thing and that's kind of in the same
type of worl budget his storytelling or
something I need to know I don't know I
just I know like he has a signature look
just hate him as a man do that do you do
super fortunate events no no but that's
very similar to that but he did that one
with Jim Carrey the original one I
haven't seen that one I just know I
don't like like the movies I've seen of
his I just don't fortunate event you've
only said three Tim Burton movies me
like I don't like Tim Burton pretty much
cool what about the [ __ ] Batman that
he did yeah yeah Michael Keaton Batman
that's my favorite one very best Batman
that has ever existed grade I agree
second one is the one with Catwoman
Nicolas Cage is that the Catwoman in
penguin no it's the one with Joker dude
with
Jack Nicholson Jack Nichols Nicolas Cage
was bad at it be incredible I know I
know that's an unpopular opinion don't
like Nightmare Before Christmas it's
okay
how about aren't out your opinion
Chocolate Factory like that maybe she
boycotted because I think whatever
Johnny Depp did from Pirates he just
[ __ ] get a new doll that goodwill
yeah he kept it like why do you gotta be
the crazy man in the desert and every
[ __ ] thing you did why I didn't like
it he keeps like recycling Johnny the
[ __ ] drugs for sure yeah I just think
Jack Sparrow became him like he became
like he just couldn't he can't shake it
off Jack Sparrow killed Johnny there
wasn't that one mob movie he did yeah
exactly Brasco no [ __ ] oh you didn't do
that well no he did do that he's not
talking about that he's talking about
that recent one yeah where he'd like
changed his face into Jack Sparrow him
fact-check myself he liked talking all
weird as [ __ ] man I was next on the list
oh well yeah Donnie Brasco is tight yeah
it's time that you tell my Tim Burton
did that I was like no Lemony Snicket's
series of unfortunate event that's not
Tim Burton I mean okay I kind of want to
hear the other list all right it's not
but they definitely love Tim Burton the
director it's okay well I do like
Maleficent
anyway all right I like that too
improvisational I like that lion is it
anyway yes exactly is there that's there
that [ __ ] as hard as [ __ ] even like all
the takes at the end of Talladega Nights
I just like to do all that all the
variations they came out with yeah so
they're saying that the fact that you
know that the person is making up the
jokes on the slot makes that sell of
comedy even funnier
I like improv doing improv at performing
improv is way different formula improv
team right here weren't you an
instructor yeah well I did all I did I
tell ya I did I did it for like 11 years
and you can't even remember big-booty
always a hit in the Miss it's like if
it's [ __ ] funny it's [ __ ]
hilarious
but it was bad it's like oh gods is
really bad but if you are forgiving
because they know that you came up on
the spot I don't think it's that
impressive to me it's not about that
it's like so what hey you be funny you
know I'm saying like it's it's it's not
about I know that the expectation is
because it's like a magic trick to
people but really it it shouldn't be it
should they should just be funny and I
think a lot of people take improv to a
crazy level where it's like all the
improv is funny because it's made up on
the spot yeah I think most improv isn't
funny I agree people are trying too hard
yeah but when people are just
freestyling and they're good at it then
it's like whoa because it's just a huge
gap between like really saw [ __ ] ton of
really sorry people and then just a
handful of really [ __ ] tight ones
right it sounds like light five wit
wordplay
it's like pun I hate mega batoon you
[ __ ] bastard filthy my wife doesn't -
it's like oh but ye - though they're
like dad jokes I know I never like
laughed at a pun till my eyes teared
true no parties upon is like punishment
yeah that's what it is right but Nicki
does it to be ironic
most the time no I hate her so that's
actually sarcasm that's actually I'm
sorry gonna actually just pun itself
it's too easy it's just it's too
it's not fun it's clever it's okay how
to [ __ ] around right yeah I just makes
me chuckle oh my god
alright next one number six topical so
this is JK news humor based on current
events or trends so like Saturday Night
Live isn't example I hate topical it
depends man it depends do I like topical
I like when they do look really cool
spin on it yeah I thought topical was
something that was used in other comedic
devices like whether it's sketch comedy
stand-up or whatever I didn't know that
was a humor in by itself no it is it's
with oral they're saying that like
sketch shows or late night late night
talk shows they require a lot of
knowledge of like what's going on right
now in the world
HD what did that just be satire oh yeah
that is but it's also top of its
topicals out there yeah cuz the content
is based off what's going that tire is
almost always dark before like almost
all truth is you have to know about
original content before you do your spin
on it yeah but topical is more like was
how right now
I like topical zein al [ __ ] we're like
getting in 2000 the debates with
bush-gore like that was some of the best
[ __ ] I ever saw I know but the bits like
the bits on O and Will Ferrell it was
great great well firs my favorite number
7 observational I like that too like
Jerry Seinfeld kind of weird things
about Society Jerry Seinfeld could
[ __ ] own you you know how dare No
wow you're in love with Jerry Seinfeld
why do I respect your side yeah I lie
Larry David better
everybody likes Larry David better now
oh yeah I didn't know how funny he was
until Curb Your Enthusiasm he's go he's
the creator of Seinfeld yeah alright
number eights bodily so farts Oh loves
us since the dawn of time they're saying
that this type of humor tends to be
popular with men and teenage if you hate
this you make comedy period all you grow
what happen what is it if you hate this
you hate comedy period that's true
because this is like the first form of
humor that you learn as a child and then
you it just goes on a breather a Charlie
Chaplin your senior dude it's so
Universal that monkeys laugh at first
yes see I'm saying about a fart I don't
even know oh you don't get it no no I
laugh but I don't know why my elementary
school teacher miss guilt consent lied
to me she said to me David because
there's this girl that farted in class
and I could not stop laughing as she
goes when you're older you will not find
this funny you blind [ __ ] it's ten
times funny it is it's a wave you know
what's even funnier than farting then I
found out later in life uncontrollable
[ __ ] yes yes fine short it twice oh
it's way funnier layers to the [ __ ] like
those LAX's scenes and movies were like
like security guards like got laxatives
and they're drinking they're trying to
[ __ ] work the keys from the door
never bridesmaids more than in the sink
right it was not [ __ ] in the middle
there's a view of the street yeah yeah
the wedding dress yeah all right last
one which was the first one you guys
mentioned which is dark dark me likes
the dark schemer so there's like this
one example here is a tweet that says we
should have died in 2012 when we had the
chance blow like all of them actually I
reminisce for the times when I was in my
high school and a little bit after that
when we could say [ __ ] like well why
don't you look yourself yeah I [ __ ]
miss it that was David's catch that was
my catchphrase on YouTube and then I got
a lot of [ __ ] for it and I still
continued say for another couple of
years
until it got too much United meeting I
was like no I still gotta see it because
I grew up saying that [ __ ] phrase he
loves my [ __ ] me too
it doesn't mean go commit suicide it's
like a [ __ ] thing it's like a [ __ ]
bid yeah it was my [ __ ] I should bring
back
[Music]
[Music]